Hi, I'm Janice Fisher in IBM Cloud
and I'm here to talk for a few minutes
about security and compliance.
Cloud computing is driving the global digital economy
and really impacting every aspect of our clients' business.
And many talk about the fact that we're in Chapter 2,
but what does that mean?
Well first, the easy part, the first 20%,
has already moved to cloud
and the difficult part, the 80%, is ahead of us.
The second thing it really means
is that we've long been talking about public cloud
but, the fact is, the future with chapter 2 is around hybrid cloud.
Customer workloads at the enterprise class level
will remain some in private cloud, some in public cloud,
and some in legacy systems.
And that's because
that's just the right thing for the enterprise.
When you focus on regulated industries
about 40%, the analysts tell us,
will move to the public cloud.
So, not everything will go there.
Regardless of how much you are moving to the public cloud,
there are two things you need.
One, providers who understand this hybrid world
and don't expect you to be in a very singular environment.
And the second is you need to expect cutting-edge security
and compliance to support this era.
IBM has a long-standing history
as a trusted and secure provider, but we do find that
the industry in general doesn't have the awareness
of the fact that our commitment to compliance
and security extends far into our
private and public cloud offerings.
We have, and are, investing heavily
to bring security and compliance
right through to the cutting-edge offerings that we have.
So, what does that mean?
One, we are secure.
Evidence?  We have invested in data, your crown jewels
as the trusted partner
to really protect that full lifecycle of data on the cloud.
It also extends the fact that
our legendary mainframe security
has become available through our cloud.
So, that's first: we are secure.
Second, we are compliant.
We have the security, privacy, and compliance programs
to address your  needs around the world.
Whether its international capabilities,
such as ISO or SOC,
regional such as GDPR in Europe,
or FedRAMP in the United States,
or industry-specific - processing credit card data,
or dealing with highly sensitive data in healthcare and financial services.
Three, we have the unique combination that hybrid cloud requires.
We have deep technical capabilities within IBM,
recently strengthened by our acquisition of Red Hat
who broadens our open capabilities
really as industry recognized leaders
who help with this pivot between public and private cloud.
We have industry insights
that our clients have leveraged for decades
- and we have the compliance experts and offerings
who really can help you deliver whether it's a global,
regional, or industry requirement.
So, I have one simple message:
IBM Cloud delivers
for thousands of customers in dozens of industries.
We're purpose-built
with controls for sensitive data
at the edge right through to the cloud,
we help customers
with their compliance and regulatory obligations
and we have what you need
to be the trusted partner on your digital transformation.
Listen, thanks for taking this time with me today.
Do you have questions?
Drop us a line below.
Do you want to see more videos like this in the future?
Be sure to "like" and subscribe
- and don't forget:
you can always get started in the cloud at no cost
by signing up for a free IBM Cloud account.